I hope he still goes to jail for
something
he should go to jail yeah he should go
to prison we're ratting on himself yeah
spreading on himself well dude you
always hear about what a [ __ ] face yeah
what a piece of [ __ ] this guy I'm
telling you I'm not rooted it's not easy
to root for this guy
[Music]
all right this is a very very simple
story but it's actually a nice one for
once I love nice finally dude so Chase
Bank accidentally deposited 50 billion
dollars into some random guys
accidentally 50 billion 50 billion
that's in oh my God I can't even fathom
that number why is that a nice story
this guy walked away with it did this
guy take out 10 mil and just like leave
the rest and just [ __ ] disappear no
he honestly
gave it back so what's the good part
about that did he call like customer
service
number two or whatever right and you're
like yeah my account is really like big
no the dude it's so honest like him and
his wife were like this isn't our money
we shouldn't keep it so they they
contacted Chase and said hey there's a
bank error all this money came in out of
nowhere and they just took it back I
guess this is better than the story of a
crypto exchange who accidentally
refunded like 10 million instead of 100
and the woman bought like a house or
something oh my God now the company is
suing her right because if you keep
money that's not technically yours when
it's given by mistake you're it's theft
right well I feel like how many stories
have we covered where somebody gets a
bunch of money from and they bail yeah
they bail and then they get [ __ ] over
even harder just because they took the
money well it's because they bail
stupidly they just moved to the city
like next over yeah what would you do
you gotta go to the [ __ ] Philippines
or some [ __ ] or Vietnam you gotta go to
a country that doesn't have extradition
with the US yeah there you go like
thinking like a [ __ ] can man has done
some research the nicest country that
doesn't have extradition yeah yeah
um I mean Lebanon has like inflation
right now but your Dollar's super strong
go to Lebanon see Lebanon no [ __ ]
Lebanon where else hey we're hey real
quick what extradition stuff they could
still assassinate you there
and Chase Bank got a lot of money what's
the nicest country that doesn't have
assassination I don't know I don't know
well nowadays I mean dude assassination
is privatized yeah you just got about a
Lebanon dude I just get an identity
change because I miss my friends you
know you gotta get like plastic surgery
yo I feel like Joe if you if you went
off the grid I think you would have a
really fun time with your new character
I know but I miss you guys though I
never I think Joe would actually make it
off the grid for like four days and then
I'm back guys honestly he's just lives
so well four days I think he's just
lived too well I think he would miss the
[ __ ] Spoils of Life yeah I just miss
my friend but you could send signals and
then your friends who come to you if we
if you guys learn smoke signaling I'm
not gonna learn smokes
no but I'm saying that's something we
should learn we should learn smoke
signaling check it out they got an
actual like visual of a god 50 billion
accidentally appearing in your account
that's too many zeros I've never even
seen that many zeros in my life and and
the hold has been removed look at that
this is an account hold that's been
removed on your 50 billion dollars yeah
so you're now free to spend your 50
billion dollars enjoy sir have a good
day dude that's so crazy and the next
one is a hundred and ten dollars
did they get a 50 Giga Olive Garden gift
certificate for this dude they didn't
get anything for it what they just took
the money back because then Chase isn't
allowed to tell you where that money
really came from
up for respect to the Privacy who's ever
won so someone made a bad transfer
something happened they did they they're
not even uh they're not even allowed to
say how it happened they typed the wrong
number when they're selling them they
were basically just like oh thank you
for telling us yeah dude this couple
goes to the bank and they take a
lollipop and then they sleep and they
they keep looking at the lollipop and
then like I should give it back
and then go back the next day and they
[ __ ] bring and they sit in 45 minutes
of traffic and then they bring it back
what if you just don't tell them and you
let it sit there for a year to see what
happens and if it's there for a year
still then I'd be like Finders Keepers
well the crazy thing is it was actually
there for three days that's too long but
that was after so immediately he told
them hey this isn't my money it took
three days for them to get it back so he
could have still [ __ ] with it but he
chose not to because you know he's
honest I hope he still goes to jail for
some explicable
himself
[Laughter]
well dude you always hear about what a
[ __ ] face yeah what a piece of [ __ ] this
guy I'm telling you I'm not rooted it's
not easy to root for this guy they asked
him like hey uh what would you do with
that money if you know they didn't take
it back and he said what a [ __ ]
question here we go what a [ __ ]
question why are you gonna ask him that
you're gonna love his answer then he
said [ __ ] up I would bless other
people to give people hope that there is
positive in the world that's what my
biggest dream I want to preach the [ __ ]
out of this [ __ ] no here's this guy's a
[ __ ] Hallmark card the one guy who
should actually get 50 billion dollars
doesn't get 50 billion dollars that's
the joke yeah
that's not him okay maybe we don't give
it to him though that's him that guy's
whack man I don't know that guy looks
like he murders people why do you think
why yeah why this foreign
this is the kind of guy that [ __ ] has
a wet dream and he like apologizes to
his wife for cheating on him exactly
right you should you should he gives her
blank divorce papers I'm so sorry I'm a
good teacher
yeah he's a nice guy
and it's crazy that he's uh I believe
he's like a like a realtor or something
so you wouldn't expect yeah he's a real
estate agent well he needs money [ __ ]
the interest rates are going up like
crazy these guys yeah no one's buying
houses right now oh but he had a former
job in law enforcement doesn't mean [ __ ]
I know so many dirty cops but that means
that means that he knew that it would be
theft yeah you know because you know
people can kind of claim I didn't know I
thought it was one I thought it was my
350 billion dollars ask me anything
about my last job I remember [ __ ] can
you forget about it
he forgets about everything being a cop
I would love to see Bart at a job for
like a day if we could film it yeah like
Bart working at Sports Authority or some
[ __ ] I love it works at a cubicle the
way that they Illustrated this amount of
money they were like this the Articles
like yeah he ended up 10 times richer
than Richard Branson that's pretty crazy
to put in that perspective like really
oh what is billion who's moving that
money billion who's moving now who
doesn't know government money that's the
thing they don't know that's but Big's
just print [ __ ] dude yeah do they well
yes and no so so so technically this is
how it works right Federal Reserve says
oh okay you could you could you can have
this money that you're gonna borrow from
me meaning like um Chase they'll take
this money from Federal Reserve you're
only you only have to have like 10 of
that zero is it zero now it was Zero for
a while I'm not sure if it still is well
I'm outdated but basically if they give
you that 10 million or whatever you
could times it by 10 or whatever the
[ __ ] you want and keep loaning that
money out so they're just printing it
based on that collateral
yeah but what's it backed by that's what
my uncle would say American tanks yep so
that's good enough for me hey did you
guys hear the Petra dollar it just got a
little weaker oh really yeah China's
moving out of the Petro dollar go figure
China and Russia is now buying [ __ ]
through what rubles or are they doing it
through yawns yeah is that the first
time where yeah that's wild because
Gaddafi got [ __ ] killed before
they're trying to do it yeah yeah yes he
sure did
but I guess China isn't gonna
untouchable now huh Gaddafi wanted to
unite uh after yeah he wanted to unite
Africa right he was like that guys he
was like we should have a United States
of Africa where we're all working
together and we can take our resources
and pull them and like make our own
currency and then we came in and killed
him and then our state department brags
about it literally brags about it we
came we saw he died and then no Gaddafi
the way he died was brutal they actually
televised it it was [ __ ] insane those
videos are still probably up on YouTube
like they um
well they they graped him with a knife
yeah it was [ __ ] crazy
but um and his friends and family and
every it's just a little example just
for those of you who want to you know
maybe go against the world order good
luck
it's very motivating that's probably why
it's scared so are you telling me to or
not
dude
what's one of those countries though
that are like they're a part of the new
world order but they're just like kind
of like the they're passive members yeah
is it the Scandinavian countries is it
like New Zealand like like the people
with neutrality because that those are
the places we could probably go you know
where it's like
you're not a big attent like it's like
America's got too much attention well a
lot of billionaires like Peter Thiel
they they either like have homes in New
Zealand or like they're trying to get
like a passport there or something oh
New Zealand yeah not totally sure why
but a lot of billionaires go to New
Zealand they have like their like
emergency escape plan yeah
I would go there's going on over there
not sure it is pretty isolated dude New
Zealand they did a uh yeah they were
super isolated during during covet but
then everything was open because there
was no in and out yeah some guy got
arrested for [ __ ] buying KFC or some
[ __ ]
Australia was it not that was New
Zealand like they like he he broke
curfew and then [ __ ] drove past them
it was Australia yeah I heard Australia
became super police state yeah Australia
was white yeah yeah they they got pretty
crazy New Zealand's chilled dude a bunch
of kiwis just [ __ ] kicking it's nice
to be on an island where did you come
from
yeah dude yeah well that's what you call
them the kiwi birds too I got a buddy
who's live in Australia and like
probably a year and a year and months
after we were all like done with like
covered lockdowny stuff he was like
showing uh me and my little group
um pictures of food that he had just
gotten a restock of because they're
going into another lockdown like it was
like that over there yeah it was crazy
holy [ __ ] crazy damn so authoritarian
over there
but probably for the best for the
citizenry so they're all nice and safe
[Music]